A diferencia de otras democracias, en
Estados Unidos
es tradicional que los partidos
políticos celebren elecciones internas
para elegir a sus candidatos. A este
sistema lo llaman elecciones primarias y
aunque a priori suene muy bonito es muy
complicado y en ocasiones injusto. Hoy, vamos
a explicarte cómo funcionan y lo vamos a
hacer de la mano de todo un experto.
Will Fox es un youtuber político: su
canal se llama Political Junkie y está
especializado en política americana.
Hola soy Will de Political Junkie News, soy
americano pero vivo en Europa y me hace
mucha gracia cuando los europeos me hacéis
siempre las mismas preguntas: ¿qué **** os
pasa a los americanos, por qué y votáis a Trump? ¿Es verdad que en EEUU todos vais
con pistola por la calle? ¿por qué no tenéis
sanidad pública? Espera... ¿Por qué
los policías van disparando a la gente
por ahí? ¿estás a favor de la guerra de Irak?
Y mi favorita de todas cuando descubren que soy de Tejas me dicen "ey, entonces eres un cowboy"
No, no soy cowboy, no tengo caballo. Yo no soy cowboy.
Hay otra pregunta que me suelen hacer, y la pregunta es ¿cómo funcionan las
elecciones primarias en Estados Unidos?
Las primarias son las elecciones
internas de los dos grandes partidos de
los Estados Unidos.
El partido demócrata que es de
izquierdas aunque su color sea azul y el
partido republicano que es de la derecha
aunque su color sea del rojo. Para elegir
a su candidato para presidente se celebra
en cada uno de los 50 estados.
Tú puedes ir, votar y después por
supuesto protestar porque al candidato
al que has elegido te ha decepcionado. ¿Parece muy fácil, verdad?
Bueno en realidad es un poco más
complicado porque en realidad no votas
a un candidato sino a unos delegados.
Pero Will, ¿qué son los delegados?
Ahora os cuento los delegados son los
que votarán por un candidato en la
convención nacional del partido que se
celebran en verano nada más que
terminan las primarias. La convenciones
nacionales son el evento en el que los
partidos nacionales los partidos
políticos seleccionan a sus candidatos
formalmente. Por ejemplo, si Donald Trump
consigue el 50% de los votos de Tejas en
teoría tendrá 50 delegados que voten
por él en la convención nacional
republicana,
así que el que tiene más delegados
gana la convención y se presenta a las
elecciones
presidenciales que se celebran en noviembre. Pero
esperad un momento que no es tan
sencillo. Resulta que en el partido
demócrata
existen una cosa que se llama "súperdelegado".
El superdelegado es una persona que pertenece
a la élite del Partido Demócrata a la
que se le permite votar a quien quiera en
la convención. Es decir, si hay un delegado de
Kansas que le eligen para que vote a Hillary Clinton durante las elecciones
primarias está obligado a votar a Hillary Clinton en la convención.
Sin embargo si esa misma persona fuera un superdelegado podría votar por
Bernie Sanders o por quien quisiera o sea
que podría darse al caso en que un
candidato tiene más votos pero pierde
la convención porque los superdelegados
deciden apoyar al contrario. Es una
locura, ¿verdad?
Los partidarios de Bernie Sanders quieren
abolir la figura de los superdelegados
en el Partido Demócrata.
Bueno así es como funciona la política
en los Estados Unidos pero ahora os
explico por qué ocurre.
Decimos que tenemos primarias para
simplificar pero en realidad algunos
estados que tienen primarias y hay
otros estados que tienen algo que se
llama caucus. En español lo pronunciamos
como caucus. ¿Y qué es un caucus? Imagínate
que eres americano y que vas a votar a Bernie Sanders en el caucus del
partido demócrata en Iowa. Llegas a
una habitación muy grande donde te
esperan otros miembros de tu comunidad.
Ahí te sientas en una mesa donde hay
otros miembros de tu comunidad que
apoyan a tu candidato. Discutís juntos
durante unos 30 minutos y si en algún
momento quieres cambiar de idea,
puedes ir a la mesa de Hillary Clinton y apoyar a Hillary Clinton. Al final
cuando ya no queda nadie discutiendo
se cuentan los votos de cada mesa y los
delegados se asignan de forma
proporcional.
pero espera porque todavía hay más.
Los delegados de los caucus de las
primarias no van directamente a la
convención nacional, normalmente se les filtra en otras convenciones más
pequeñas a nivel local, de distrito o
de estado.
Por eso los partidarios de Hillary Clinton y Bernie Sanders están
discutiendo todo el día. Es una chapuza
de sistema, ¿verdad? "And WTF means 'chapuza'?"
Pues ahora os voy a decir algo más que os
va a terminar de romper los esquemas: en
realidad casi nadie y participa en las
primarias. En el 2012 sólo el 16%
de los americanos eligió a sus
candidatos.
Y en estas elecciones sólo 30% de la
población de los votantes se ha animado
a meter su papeleta. O sea, cuando decís
que los americanos estamos locos a votar
por votar a Donald Trump pensad que
sólo le habrán votado 12 ó 13
millones de personas y que esto sólo es
el 42% de los votos de los republicanos
en la primaria republicana. O sea, que ni
siquiera la mayoría de los
conservadores le apoyan.
Dicho de otra forma menos del 4% de la población americana ha
votado a Donald Trump en esta elección, en
esta primaria.
Sin embargo todos los americanos tendremos
que decidir si nos gusta o no durante
las elecciones de noviembre.
¡Bienvenidos a la política americana!
Si os apetece aprender más de la
política de los Estados Unidos o simplemente
si queréis mejorar vuestro inglés pues, por
favor visitadme en mi canal Political
Junkie News, haced clic aquí.
En Political Junkie News encontraréis un montón de vídeos sobre la
política y la historia. ¡Hasta luego!